[Music]
here's a question for you do you do you
profile no no no so you pick everybody
everybody that's a damn lie you know
evany homeless guys standing it but he
he called you you see new who not only
has but he's got different cards and
literally switches of his cards on the
regular question Anthony he would rolled
up and you hadn't recognized this and we
were just wearing trash bags
would you have led us into the car just
trash bags and it was clear that I had
into mine yeah that's called a good
kind of profile ooh - boo boo
my demographic yo you've got to do mine
are all names Nigel Badgers I got
Swisher sweet know what is the banner
guys no no no for the driver the driver
driver Jim we're about to go to jail I
think I do quite well in jail gentlemen
that's all I'm saying
I am one hard
the most I've ever seen you laughter
we're we're - next we're going to love
art I was Boulevard
those guys were cool costumes and I want
to meet them hey be careful man be
careful them dudes in costumes on
Hollywood Boulevard maybe have an
attitude sometime so maybe they'll be
ready in case we have to kick somebody
ass oh yeah I got no problem with
spider-man ass like spongebob anybody
you know they want to get a little
little funky tongue you know what I mean
I hope it happens wait a minute
peaceful people no no but if it does go
down he's going down this is old it's
all done through the app wait a minute
this is on my credit card
yeah it's been running for a bit score
burn this is counting just try and calm
down and those exciting for you I'll
have the ten piece of the 10-piece
chicken nugget I also want four loaded
baked potatoes I want four loaded baked
potatoes I don't have any money okay I
guess this is on me huh
I just told Conan I don't have any money
so he's paying for it look
now we get to rate you after this you do
out of five stars all right
okay what are you gonna give me if I
know we missed points taking off today
well I do know have a couple
dispensaries no legal weed okay you
don't it don't taste as good is that
true
of course Conan we're gonna be honest
for a second here say something be
honest for a second here
you two talk to me like I'm a child you
talk down to me
you talk to me like I'm not cool like I
don't know what time it is
shut up no we don't you know what that
was a good point yeah it's Matt Matt
what's up man he got his ass locked down
that's what's going on not you you are
currently talking to mr. Ice Cube mr.
Kevin Hart and mr. Conan O'Brien they've
had they've hijacked my lift look put it
this way you want to see your friend I
suggest you show up and mean it's a
Hollywood Boulevard
at the FedEx on top of the F and I
suggest you do what we say before Conan
carry out his actions you punk tell me
this is not a joke we want weed laptops
a washing machine
I want hair care products yeah you get a
good time you don't be cheap you son of
a Wow
I want a Frederic Fekkai conditioner and
some space off row and some space off
row you find me some decks you get Kevin
some dacks and then you meet us at the
FedEx on top of the app and
bring some weed and knock a card from
them from the fancy stores we want the
card from the do what we don't know he
got it bottom line understand something
white boy this is why he's Mexican hey
mexicana
you you know do not barked up the wrong
tree
[Music]
[Applause]